The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So today we start a new
topic, but in the same spirit
of PSPACE completeness
of puzzles.
We're going to talk
about a general theory
called Constraint Logic.
This was the topic
of the Ph.D. thesis
here by Bob Hearn, which later
turned into this book-- Games,
Puzzles, and Computation.
And constraint logic
is a big theory.
But today we're going to focus
on one particular aspect of it
called nondeterministic
constraint logic.
Nondeterministic like NP.
And that is specifically
about puzzles
and PSPACE completeness.
So non-deterministic constraint
logic-- usually called NCL.
And it's a very
useful infrastructure
for proving PSPACE
hardness results,
for puzzles, originally
motivated by sliding blocks,
but we will get
there in a moment.
You've seen it very
briefly in Lecture 1.
I'm going to go through it
again more slowly and clearly
and define everything.
And then we'll see lots of
hardness proofs based on that.
So we start with the
notion of a machine.
We won't use this term too much.
But the idea is we start
with an undirected graph.
Think of this as a
model of computation.
So your computer is
an undirected graph
of red edges and blue edges.
Red edges have weight 1.
Blue edges have weight 2.
And then a configuration
of that machine--
or a constraint
graph in total-- is
an orientation of that graph.
So it's really a directed
graph with red and blue edges.
And you have to satisfy the
constraint that at every node,
the total incoming weight
should be at least 2.
So either at least one blue
edge or at least two red edges.
So this should be a
satisfying assignment.
This one has two red edges.
This one has actually one blue
edge and an additional red edge
coming in.
But in general we have--
so, a constraint graph.
It's going to be a directed
red/blue graph satisfying,
I'll call it the
inflow constraint,
that for every vertex, the
total incoming weight is
greater than or equal to 2 where
red is a 1 and a blue is a 2.
And then we're interested
in reconfigurations
of constraint graphs by
reversing one edge at a time.
So let's look at a vertex here.
This guy has total incoming
weight of three-- one
from the red, two from the blue.
And a move we're
allowed to do is
say, reverse an edge like this.
So now we have a total
incoming weight of 4.
4 is also greater
than or equal to 2.
So that's a valid move.
Now we could also
reverse this edge.
We couldn't before.
If we had done it
in the beginning,
there would only be a
weight of 1 coming in.
But now that we have these
two units of weight coming in,
we can redirect this--
at least local to this
vertex-- we can
redirect this guy.
It'll only make
this vertex happier.
The validity of this
move depended on what
that vertex looked like.
So in general, we start
with some constraint graph.
We're going to do a
sequence of moves.
At all times we should
have a valid constraint
graph, meaning you satisfy
the inflow constraint.
So those are the
rules of the game.
And at each move, or
at each time step,
you can make any
valid move you want.
That's the
nondeterministic aspect.
And that mimics most puzzles.
You're not told
which move to do.
You get to choose
Guess which move
to do, if you like.
So the NCL problem
is, I give you
some crazy network like this.
And I want to know, can I
reverse a particular edge?
That's one version
of the problem.
There are actually two decision
problems we can think about.
That one is the most useful.
Or most common, I should say.
Can you reverse a specified
edge given the constraint graph?
Meaning is there a
sequence of moves--
and the last move is
reversing the target edge.
Another problem
would be, can you
reach a desired other
constraint graph?
So I give you an
entire configuration
and another orientation of
the graph that's consistent.
And to in some sense, that
gives you more information.
I don't just say I
want to flip this edge.
It will actually be, I
want to flip this edge
and no other edges is going
to be the typical setup.
But in general, I give you
one configuration and another.
And I want to know, can I get
from here to here by a sequence
of single-edge reversals.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does the graph
[INAUDIBLE] degree 3?
PROFESSOR: It will
always be max degree 3.
So you can assume that.
In fact, we will show
both of these problems
are PSPACE complete for
three regular graphs.
Although what I've drawn
here is not three regular.
It has some vertices
in degree 1.
You can actually
assume max degree 3.
And you can assume
that there are only
two types of
vertices-- and those
are red, red, blue
and blue, blue, blue.
So even just for these
two types of vertices,
both of these problems
are PSPACE complete.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do degree
1 vertices also
have to satisfy the
inflow constraint?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
This would not be valid.
We'll show how to
simulate degree 1 vertices
with or without the
inflow constraint.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the
problem given the graph,
find a valid configuration?
PROFESSOR: That's a
different problem.
Given an undirected graph,
find a valid configuration.
That problem is NP complete.
We'll also prove that.
That's called constraint
graph satisfiability.
So that's an analog of SAT.
So this is, given
undirected red/blue graph,
find a valid orientation.
So that's a good question.
At present, there aren't very
many NP hardness reductions
that use this problem.
But I think maybe
there should be more.
It's a need.
This was not our original
goal with constraint logic.
So we sort of forgot
about it until recently.
We thought it would
be cool to do more.
AUDIENCE: So the
separation suggests
that you can't get from
any valid configuration
to any other valid
configuration?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So in particular, for
lots of different pairs
of configurations
of the same graph,
you cannot find a path
from one to the other.
And deciding whether you
can is PSPACE complete.
I mean, that implies there
are lots of no answers.
AUDIENCE: So what
prevents you from being
able to do it intuitively?
PROFESSOR: Hopefully it will
become more and more obvious.
I don't have a great
intuition why it's
hard, other than it's hard.
I mean, you tend to get
nice path connectivity
in continuous spaces.
This is a very discrete space.
And there's a lot
of hard constraints
that's like rough intuition.
AUDIENCE: You'll probably
get into this later,
but can you give us some
brief motivation of why
we care about this problem?
PROFESSOR: The
motivation is a lot
of puzzles can easily simulate
these kinds of pictures.
And in particular, you
basically need two gadgets.
And we'll also prove that this
is hard for planar graphs.
So you don't even
need a crossover.
For planar red/blue graphs,
with just these two types
of vertices, the whole
problem is PSPACE complete.
So the ultimate
motivation is to prove
your problem PSPACE complete.
If it falls into the
category of games like this,
you just need two gadgets.
And you get a proof
by two pictures.
So that will lead to some very
efficient PSPACE completeness
proofs.
Of course, to get there we first
need to prove this theorem.
And I'm going to do
that first so you
see where all this
comes from, so you
don't have to understand it.
I think it's helpful in case
you want to generalize it.
OK.
So let me tell you about
these two types of vertices.
This one is called
an AND vertex.
And this one is
called an OR vertex.
Because if we think of the
two red edges as inputs,
and think of the
blue edge as output,
this picture is
supposed to represent
that 1 and 1 equals 1.
And this picture is supposed to
represent that 0 or 0 equals 0.
And if we do some more moves,
like if I flip this edge,
now I have total
incoming weight of 3.
That's still not enough
to flip this edge,
because 0 and 1 is 0 still.
And I could flip it back.
Maybe I flip the other edge.
Also 1 and 0 is 0.
Still can't flip this guy.
But if I flip both of them up
top, if both of the red guys
are incoming, then I can if I
want to flip the bottom edge.
But I don't have to right away.
So I could go from here to here.
But this is sort
of a slow AND gate.
I put in the two 1 inputs.
I don't yet have a 1
output, so to speak,
where 1 here is
represented by 2.
You get the idea.
OK.
So let me write
down the definition
to make that slightly cleaner.
So I'm going to define
the activation of an edge,
or an edge being activated.
An input edge is going to
be active if it's incoming.
And an output edge is
active if it's outgoing.
This is a symmetric.
Incoming and outgoing
always clear.
Either you're going
into the vertex,
or you're going
out of the vertex.
But just by labeling
these inputs,
I'm going to say these edges are
sort of interesting if they're
pointing in.
This edge is interesting
if it's pointing out.
These correspond to the one
bits in a Boolean logic.
And what we say for an AND
gate-- property of an AND
gate-- is that the
output can activate--
doesn't have to-- only if
both inputs are active.
So in this language you can
see that it's an AND gate.
You need both of the inputs.
The AND of the input should be
active in order for the output
to activate.
And so that's why we do
this asymmetric thing.
Another reason to do this
asymmetric view of inputs
and outputs is if
you have two vertices
and an edge between them.
It was asymmetric to
begin with, right?
This edge from this guy's
perspective is outgoing.
From this guy's
perspective, it's incoming.
That's annoying to deal with.
I want the edge to
either be active or not.
And if this is the output
edge of this vertex,
and it's the input
of this vertex,
than this edge is active.
And the other direction
would be inactive.
OK.
But it's active from
this guy's perspective.
And it's active from
So while this may
seem asymmetric,
it actually makes the
picture more symmetric.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can't have a red
edge being the output, though.
Right?
PROFESSOR: That's true.
With these gadgets we never
have a red edge being output.
Imagine red being blue.
OK.
So that is active.
And AND, you have sort
of delayed outputs.
You can think of
this same vertex
if you relabel these
guys as outputs,
and this guy as an input.
It's just a perspective change.
It's just changing terminology.
So it doesn't actually
change what happens.
But from this perspective.
You essentially are splitting,
or fanning out, a wire.
So if you have a
signal here of true--
so this is an active input
now-- that both of these
can be active if
they want to be.
They don't have to be.
But if it's false, then both
of these have to be inactive.
This is inactive.
Both of these have
to be inactive.
And there are lots of
configurations of this guy.
So maybe some of them point in.
So the split.
That's the same vertex that's
a relabeling of who's active
and who's inactive.
The outputs can activate
only if the input is active.
And really, I should be
saying if and only if.
But I'm being a
little concise here.
OK.
So that's a SPLIT vertex.
And then the other
vertex type is an OR.
So this is really the second
vertex type out of three.
Third out of three.
Whatever.
So this of course
looks very symmetric.
I mean, there's no clear notion
of inputs or outputs here.
But if you define two
of them to be inputs,
and the other one
to be an output,
then that output is the
OR of those two inputs.
This edge can activate only
if this edge is active,
or this edge is active, or both.
So it's an inclusive OR.
Probably have some animations.
Like if I flip this
guy, now this one
can choose to activate.
I could also have both of them
in, or just one of them in.
But in order for this one to
now go back out and deactivate,
this when would first
have to deactivate.
So that's ANDs and ORs.
You get some sense for why
this is a Boolean logic.
One point to make at this
point is that I do not
have a NOT gadget.
And in fact, NOT gadgets are
impossible in this universe.
Because we're always talking
about outputs can activate,
but they don't have to, it's up
to the non-deterministic player
to choose whether to activate
an output, or when to do it,
NOT is impossible.
Because a NOT would
be something like,
this edge cannot activate if
this other edge is active.
This output cannot activate
if this input is active.
That would be the idea.
Maybe output is inactive
if the input is active.
And that kind of constraint
is impossible to represent
with a lower bound
on incoming weight.
Maybe if you had an upper
bound, you could do it.
But with a lower
bound, you're always
happier to have inputs active.
So if it worked with
the input inactive
that the output could
activate, then it
should also work with
the input active.
NOT gates are impossible.
So that's a little
bit annoying, but it
won't be too much trouble.
We've in some sense dealt
with that in other proofs.
Before I get to these
hardness results,
let me tell you a
few other vertices
that are helpful, and can be
simulated with ANDs and ORs.
So one of them is
a choice vertex.
This is sort of like an
exclusive OR, in a sense.
So two of these edges
must be incoming--
in the symmetric picture--
two of them must be incoming.
At most, one of them
can be outgoing.
And this can be simulated
by expanding this
into a little triangle.
So if this guy is outgoing,
then both of these
must be pointing to it.
And once both of these
are pointing out,
then the blues must
be pointing in here,
because the red would
not be enough to make
either of these vertices happy.
If this guy's making
that guy happy.
So if one of them is out,
the other two must be in.
We'll see how to use
this in a second.
But it's useful to have
red, red, red in addition
to red, red, blue;
and blue, blue, blue.
OK.
Now one issue that arises here,
as you're probably guessing,
especially when I did this kind
of transformation where I said,
oh, three red vertices.
That's just like this picture,
except these are now blue.
That's not going to work
so well from whatever
they're attached to.
Now luckily, we
can deal with this.
The more direct
version is if we're
trying to build some Boolean
formula like an AND of ORs,
the inputs are in the bottom.
Because these are the
inputs to the AND.
The AND wants its
input to be red.
But the OR is providing
an output which is blue.
How come we convert a
red edge to a blue edge?
Luckily, we can do it.
As long as we have
an even number
of red to blue
conversions, we can
fill in this gadget in
between, and it works.
So basically this is in
a forced configuration.
I think it can't change at all.
At least from this
position, it can't change.
What we need at this stage is
that these guys can point out--
both of them.
So you always get a
weight boost of one
from both of these vertices.
And so now if this
guy's pointing in,
that's a total weight of 2.
And so then this
guy can point out.
Of course, as this
guy is pointing in,
this guy can point out.
And it's symmetric
on the two sides.
So maybe you do try to
mess with this gadget.
Although I don't think you can.
What we need is that you are
allowed to leave it like this,
and you get a bonus point
for each of those vertices,
and all is well.
And we'll see later how to make
an even number of conversions.
Now one thing I should maybe
mention at this point also--
this is sort of a
technical detail--
but if you used to think of
this as a single edge, when
I reversed it-- let's say
it was pointing up before,
and I make it point
down-- this vertex
will see that
effect immediately.
This vertex doesn't see it yet.
So it's kind of an even
more delayed reaction.
Because we subdivided
an edge into two parts,
we can flip one side without
having flipped the other side.
The way I would view this is in
the original constraint logic
graph, we used to have
an edge pointing up.
We change it into
an undirected edge.
It has no orientation because
it doesn't benefit either side.
It's pointing away
from both ends.
And then we choose to
direct it the other way.
So this is an alternative view
of a move in a constraint graph
that used to be you're
reversing an edge.
Another view is that you
can change a directed edge
into an undirected edge.
And you can change an undirected
edge into a directed edge.
So these models are
almost identical.
In fact, you can prove they're
exactly the same power.
And they're called
asynchronous constraint logic.
So if you were worried about
that, you don't need to worry.
I won't prove here that
they're identical power,
but it's not hard.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What was the thing
where [INAUDIBLE] that you
can't flip those colors?
Cause you can flip
the colors, right?
But you can flip
the two red arrows
AUDIENCE: In.
AUDIENCE: Inwards.
And then you can flip the
blue to cover the top node.
AUDIENCE: Basically
flip all of them.
AUDIENCE: So the thing--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: And the
best you can do is--
PROFESSOR: You can't put
flip these red guys yet.
Are you going to flip
this blue guy first?
But how?
AUDIENCE: Well, you
can't do anything first.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Nothing can happen first.
There is another configuration.
But from here, I
think it's rigid.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: There's
nothing that can change.
You can't flip this guy because
this guy would be unhappy.
Therefore, you
can't flip this guy.
Therefore, you can't
flip these guys.
Therefore, you
can't flip this guy.
So I think you get a cycle,
and nothing can happen first.
But we don't need that here.
We will need it later.
That's why I wanted to mention.
OK.
So we can convert reds to blues.
So now we can chain
things together
and build a CNF formula.
As long as we
represent-- so here
we're going to use a choice
gadget to say-- so right now,
nothing is activated.
Our goal is to
activate that edge
at the top that's
going to represent
that Boolean formula, the
satisfiability of that Boolean
formula.
We use a choice gadget to say,
look, either W can activate,
or Wbar can activate.
We need some notion of negation.
And this is how
we're going to get
our negation, which is normally
called dual real logic.
You have one
channel representing
X, one representing Xbar.
We have this extra
straggler, which we basically
don't care about.
Right now it is taking
the weight somewhere.
But you can push it up.
If we plug-in a suitable
terminator down there,
which we'll need to talk about.
But then, other than
red/blue conversions,
then we are basically
doing an OR.
We have to do an
OR of three things,
and we only have degree 3.
So we do an OR of two things.
That gives this output.
Then we take an OR
of the other thing.
So now this output is
the OR of three things.
We convert it into a red edge.
This is a reference to
the gadget we just saw.
And then we can
take an AND, here
we're taking an AND
of three things.
In general, it would be
an AND of end things.
We build a binary
tree of those ANDs.
And so that edge can
reverse if and only
if that formula is satisfiable.
Assuming we know what to
do with degree 1 vertices.
So this represents CNF.
Let me tell you what to
do with degree 1 vertices.
Here are three
different gadgets,
depending on what
you want to do.
On the one hand, this is an
unconstrained blue terminator.
All the vertices are
happy even locally.
And so this edge
can go up or down.
I think that's pretty clear.
This guy already has
two incoming edges.
Everybody has at least one.
And the point here is
it's three regular.
So this is actually
a kind of classic way
to make a three regular graph
out of a degree 1 vertex.
On the other hand, we can
do the same thing with red.
And actually, the reason I
wanted two incoming edges here
is when I recolor
them red, that still
makes this vertex satisfied.
So this guy can go up or down.
Now you might say why do I
care about a blue terminator
separate from a red
terminator, because I already
have red to blue conversion.
Because red/blue
conversion-- assume
that the number of red/blue
conversions was even.
And this is how I'm
going to make it even.
If it's not even, I'll take
any of my degree 1 vertices
and add an extra red/blue
conversion there.
Now it will be even,
because it was odd before.
But I need either a
red or blue terminator,
whatever I didn't have before.
So this is where we'll get that.
And it's easy to do.
In the middle we have
a different thing.
This forces this edge
to be pointed down.
That's useful in some
scenarios for example.
So back to this picture.
One thing I've done is we
have these floating edges
that we want to throw away.
We can just use a red terminator
unconstrained for that.
So that guy can do
whatever he wants.
That still lets you choose
W or Wbar to be true.
If I shrink this picture a
little bit more and put here,
this is I guess a
free terminator.
I don't care whether
this guy's used also.
But I would really like
this edge to be directed up.
This is, of course,
locally invalid.
You have to put in a satisfying
assignment to make this go up.
So this is how we can
prove that constraint graph
satisfiability, finding an
orientation is NP complete
if we use that
terminator on the top.
In the undirected
form, this thing
will force this
edge to be up, which
means it will force this
thing to be satisfied,
or there won't be a
valid orientation,
which means there's
no satisfying
assignment to that formula.
So that's one way you
could use the terminators.
We'll use them in other ways.
AUDIENCE: Can we just use a
[INAUDIBLE] red terminator
instead of the red-- to
do a red [INAUDIBLE],
instead of the slightly more
complicated thing we actually
did?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
red terminator
has a vertex with
three red edges.
PROFESSOR: That's OK.
But maybe that's relevant.
So this is going
to expand to this.
And that requires a
red/blue conversion.
There we go.
That's why.
So we're actually already
using a red/blue conversion
of this style in here.
All right.
Let's move on to more
interesting things.
So that was constraint graph
satisfactions NP complete.
Let's go to the reconfiguration
problems being PSPACE complete.
So now I want to do a sequence
of moves and flip one edge,
or reach a desired
configuration.
We'll start with just
flipping one edge.
We're going to follow the
same kind of prototype
that we saw last class, with
[? Viglietta's ?] Proof, where
we're going to reduce from QSAT.
So we have this alternating
set of quantifiers, variables.
And then we have
some Boolean formula.
We'll assume it's in CNF
form, because we just
showed how to do CNF formulas.
And we're going to
represent variables
by two rails, x and x bar.
And these things are essentially
nested inside each other,
and there's some
magic mechanisms
to glue them together.
So in particular, let's see.
At the end here, so
suppose these variables,
the idea is that one of
them will be pointing up
and the other will
be pointing down.
That corresponds
to x being true.
If y bar is pointing up
and y is pointing down,
then y bar will be true.
In other words, y will be false.
So then this thing will
do its computation.
And then the output
wire is this one.
So we'll be pointing
out of the CNF logic,
if and only if that formula
without the quantifiers
was satisfied.
OK.
Now here we have an AND gate.
And we have a signal from
this gadget saying basically,
all the variables are set.
And here it's called try out.
We'll see what that means.
Basically I want to check
whether this thing is true.
And if the try out
is pointing out,
and the satisfy thing
then this guy can
point to the left.
And so that will
tell this gadget
that yes, it is satisfied.
So when activated, and this
thing has become satisfied,
then we will report
back to that gadget.
In general, each of the
quantifier gadgets--
this is an existential one,
this is the universal one.
Don't look at them in
too much detail yet.
But there will be one input
here, which is a try in.
And there'll be an output,
which is a try out, to say,
when I'm told by the previous
gadget to do something,
I'll do something.
Then I'll tell the next
gadget to do something.
And if that gadget reports
back with a positive answer,
in this case, I just return
that positive answer back
to my caller.
So this is the input
and the output.
And same thing for universal.
It's going to have a try in.
It's going to
activate a try out.
Then if it gets a satisfied
end, stuff will happen.
And eventually we might
output a satisfied out.
So these things are
supposed to just chain
together left and right.
So let's look at each
gadget individually,
and in particular, you will
see this triangle pattern--
the blue, blue, red triangle--
in a few different places.
That's a useful
construction by itself.
Let's think about that first.
It's called a latch.
It's like a one-bit memory.
Currently the latch is locked.
When this edge out is
pointing to the left,
then nothing over
here can change.
There are actually two
possible states here.
But if this is
pointing out, this guy
can't flip, which means
these two can't flip,
which means this one can't flip.
OK.
I guess this guy could reverse.
But that's all.
So this is in a state where
A can output something,
but B cannot.
Now I can flip it to the
other symmetric state,
where B can output
something and A cannot.
But to do that, I first
must unlock the gadget,
unlock the latch by
flipping this edge.
If I can flip this edge,
then everything becomes free.
Now I can flip this edge.
And then I can flip
B actually now.
Both A and B can output, which
is kind of a weird state.
But in particular, I
can flip this edge.
And then maybe put A back.
That will let me flip this guy.
And now this guy's
happy from this edge.
And so I can relock the
gadget if I want to.
If I click hard enough.
So now we're back
in a lock state.
And now B can output.
It could choose to not output.
But B can output.
A cannot.
So when the gadget
is in a lock state,
we get at most one signal from
A or B. And it can't change.
When we unlock, then we can do
crazy stuff, have both of them
output, whatever.
But then when we relock, we know
that only one of them is on.
And that's our one-bit memory.
At this point, it's a
nondeterministic memory.
You can basically set it to
a nondeterministic value,
and then lock it down.
OK.
This is great for
existential quantifiers.
That's basically all we need
for an existential quantifier.
When we're told do
something, we're
going to convert
that blue to a red.
So right now this
vertex is happy,
because we haven't told the
next gadget to do anything.
This edge is
pointed to the left.
So this thing can go up or
down, whatever it wants.
So basically we are free
to unlock this and set it
to either value.
So where x is pointing out,
or x bar is pointing out,
or neither.
But the direction of
this edge will sort of
keep track of which
thing is being set.
Then the next thing can activate
only when this is pointing out,
which means the latch is locked.
So when we activate
the next existential
or universal quantifier,
or the overall formula,
we know both that
we're told we're
activated from the
left, which means
all the variables
to the left have
been locked into their state.
And we know from this
AND gate that this
has been locked into its state.
So it has only x or x bar set.
And then we can proceed.
And for existential quantifier,
that's all you need.
That there's some
value, some setting
for x, that satisfies the rest.
And so if you get satisfied
from the rest of the formula,
you know you are satisfied.
And so here we're using
the nondeterminism
of the player to make the right
call whether to set x or x bar.
That's the easy case.
The harder case is the
universal quantifier.
Here we actually
use two latches.
And there's a bunch of lines.
So what's the idea?
This is viewed as
a split gadget.
So if we activate here,
we can do that only
with this pointing down.
OK.
Fine.
And this points over.
For the computation to
proceed, to do a try out,
we need that we are
active from the try in.
But also, this latch
must be locked.
This is the locking
mechanism of that latch.
So when both of
these are incoming,
then we will call the
rest of the construction.
Again, this is just setting
x or x bar, just like before.
But we're making
copies of x and x bar.
So this is a split gadget.
If we have this set, we
can set both this copy
of x and this copy of x.
If we have this one set, we
can set this copy of x bar
and this copy of x bar.
So those are splits.
OK.
So now, what about this latch?
So this is the locking
mechanism of that latch.
And what we're saying
is that if x bar is set,
and the formula is satisfied,
then we can unlock this latch
and set it to something.
Now we will want to set
it so that this edge is
pointing down.
Initially this edge will
probably be pointing out.
It doesn't have to, though.
So we don't really
care about this edge.
It doesn't bias
anything, this edge.
Because we're going to have
a blue thing coming in,
so we don't really care
which way this edge goes.
We really want to set this edge.
So if you're the
nondeterministic player,
and suddenly this
latch is open, you
will want to rearrange it
so that it points down.
Why?
Because we want to
satisfy this thing.
And this is an AND of
this edge and that edge.
So what this is saying is
we can turn this latch on,
meaning pointing down here, only
if for the false setting of x,
we get a satisfied thing.
Cause here again, we're
taking a satisfied thing
and splitting it into two parts.
And so satisfied in is true.
And x bar is true.
Then we can activate this
latch and set to the new thing.
Now what do you do?
Now we're going
to lock the latch,
and then roll back the
entire computation.
Undo everything.
In this world,
everything's reversible.
If you can reverse an edge,
you can also put it back.
OK.
So now unwind everything.
Come back to this place and
unlock this latch again.
And now set x to true
instead of false.
And then once this is
locked in the true state,
we can again activate tryout.
And now we're going to
come back through here.
We don't care about this latch.
We're now going to
use this vertex.
This is the AND of being
satisfied and having
x being true.
So if we're satisfied
with x true,
then this edge will be
pointing to the left.
And if we already
remembered the fact
that when we set x to
false, we also got true,
then this AND will be true.
And then we can output that.
OK?
So this is why you don't want to
reduce from QSAT all the time.
There are these annoying
gadgets you have to build.
But now once you
have this, we just
need to build ANDs and
ORs, which is much easier.
AUDIENCE: If we
have nondeterminism,
do we ever have to
roll back things?
Can't we just set
it to the right one?
PROFESSOR: No.
With the universal
quantifier for all--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
PROFESSOR: You need
to check both of them.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you need
to build crossovers
for this gadget to work?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
We would need crossovers.
But we'll get there.
So we're not yet
doing planar graphs.
At this point, I think we have
proved by this construction
that for nonplanar graphs,
and only AND and OR gates,
we have PSPACE completeness
of flipping one edge.
OK.
Now what if you wanted to
go from one configuration
to another?
Then I could just
put a latch here
that's unlocked by this thing.
The goal usually is,
can I flip this edge.
Because if I can
flip this edge, that
means the whole formula is true.
So all the quantifier
constructions.
If I put a latch here, and
I can activate the latch
and then change
its state, then I
could roll back
everything else, and I
would back to the
original state,
except the latch is flipped.
And that will be possible
only if the formula is true.
So that's how you can predict
the entire configuration.
Nothing will have
changed, except this one
edge, two edges.
Whatever.
So next question is planarity.
But for nonplanar
graphs, we're good.
Here's a crossover.
It's a little bit annoying, I
mean, to check all the cases.
But this is going to be
a blue, blue crossover.
So basically these
three edges will
be in the same
orientation, roughly.
And these three
edges will be-- I
mean I can't say they're
always in the same orientation.
Because there's a
transition period.
So I think they
could both point in.
That's like an undirected edge.
But if this guy's
pointing to the left,
then this guy must
point to the left.
Why?
Cause this points to the
left, and both of these
are pointing to the left.
This is pointing
either up or down.
Let's say it's pointing up.
That will actually have to
do with the other edges.
But if it's pointing
up, and this
is pointing left-- oh, notice
here I have a degree 4.
It's another gadget.
Please wait.
But this is the
usual constraint.
There must be a weight of
at least two coming in.
And so if both of these are out,
then both of these must be in.
If this is this way, then
this must be to the left.
So if this is to the left,
then this must be to the left.
And by the same argument,
this must be to the left.
So that's how you
transition horizontally.
And it's a similar
thing vertically.
If this is pointing
up, then both of these
must be pointing
into that vertex.
And this guy's either
pointing left or right.
That depends on the other edge.
But let's say it's
pointing to the right.
So if that's pointing to
the right, both of these
are pointing to the
right, which means
both of these are pointing
out, which means both of these
must be pointing in.
And so if this is pointing
out, this is pointing up.
I mean, it depends.
If this is pointing up,
then this is pointing up.
Or this is pointing up.
One of them, depending on
the state of this edge.
But then you can use that again
to prove this is pointing up.
So it could be they're both
pointing in here or here.
But that's like an
undirected edge.
And so if you believe in
asynchronous constraint logic,
this is simulating
the crossover.
So except we have degree 4
red, red, red, red vertices.
So we need one more
gadget, which is this one.
This essentially
simulates, of course,
the edges here are blue.
That's why I've drawn
off to the side.
Now here we have to
be a little careful,
because we need that the
red/blue transitions do not
introduce crossings.
Because if we did, we'd have
to use a crossover gadget.
And we'd get in this
infinite recursion.
But you can just stick this
on here and turn it red,
and connect it to this guy,
and similarly over here.
And you convert them all the
red without any crossings.
And I think I won't go
through this gadget,
but it simulates the
constraint that at least two
of these edges must be
pointing into the gadget.
Cool.
So that was a blue,
blue crossover.
If you have a red,
blue crossover,
or red, red crossover,
again convert red to blue,
and then back again.
One more version.
So we just did planar
graphs, or PSPACE complete.
If you draw your
planar graph in a grid,
naturally you would
also want the ability
to just take an edge and
go left or make a turn.
So do we need turn gadgets
and straight gadgets?
The answer is no.
We can use ANDs and ORs.
Actually we can just use ANDs
to simulate wires and turns.
So suppose this is one of
the gadgets that takes inputs
from two adjacent sides
and outputs on one
of the other adjacent sides.
Then it's always going to
look like this pattern,
all of the instances of the
AND gate are rotations of that.
I think no reflections.
So first we build these fillers.
These fillers, I guess we'll
give them some initial state
where we get to choose.
So maybe I think I want all
these edges to be pointing out.
So I'm going to set
everything to 0.
It's going to be
0 and 0 equals 0.
So that's locally
consistent within the cycle.
And it means that this
edge is free to point out
if it wants to.
So in particular, I guess I want
these four wires to be zeroes.
And so then this
one could be 01,
and still consistent
with the ANDs.
And so that means when
I put that box here,
this is one of those
filler gadgets,
that I have one unit
of flow-- because those
are red edges-- pointing out.
And so in particular here,
if I have a unit here,
I get a free unit from the
side, and therefore the AND
will be the same as the input.
So I put two by two blocks here.
I also have a
similar two by three
block, which I put
in these chunks.
And then this will just
copy whatever value
is here, up there.
Again,
nondeterministically, we can
have both of them pointing
in, but this one can point out
only if this one can point in.
This can activate only
if this can activate.
That's a straight.
Turn is similar.
And if you want to do
an actual computation,
you put whatever gadget
is you want to compute,
and use these to copy the data.
Question.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Do you have [INAUDIBLE]?
I'm sorry.
The square filler into the top
right of the straight grid.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's a
terminator at the input--
PROFESSOR: Oh.
You mean there's an
edge here which doesn't
have anything on the side.
That's true.
Yes.
So that's this little thing.
So in this particular world,
this won't work for all proofs,
but it's sort of an example
of what you could do.
There needs to be an input
here which you ignore.
So it's like a degree 1 vertex.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And then we can [INAUDIBLE]
everything's OK.
PROFESSOR: I mean,
the point is you
have to only build
one gadget-- or two
gadgets, the AND and the OR.
But it has to have this feature
that when you stick them
on the-- you stick
an input to this gate
into a non-used neighboring
side from this gate,
then it just works.
So we'll see an example
where that happens.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you turn right?
PROFESSOR: I'm
guessing to turn right,
we might actually need the
reflected form of the AND.
But most gadgets, if it works
one way and you reflect it,
it also works.
So yeah.
Good.
One more.
AUDIENCE: Silly question
about what nondeterministic
means in this case.
Since we've been using
nondeterministic to mean
you can guess correctly.
And to mean that the [INAUDIBLE]
aren't being reflected.
So what exactly does it mean?
PROFESSOR: What was
the second version?
The edges--
AUDIENCE: About the edges
taking a while to transfer.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
No sir, that was asynchronous.
Asynchronous is that
they take awhile.
Nondeterministic is
that the player gets
to choose which edge to flip.
They're related.
I mean, asynchrony
kind of comes out
of this form of
nondeterminism that we have.
But they don't have to be.
The way I originally
set the models,
when you flip an
edge instantaneously.
In both the gadgets that we
build, like the actual AND
and OR gates we build
for real problems,
they will actually take
awhile to activate.
You'll like pull some
things in, and stuff
happens before you can
pull some things out.
So we will naturally
get asynchrony.
The way is originally set it
up, it was just nondeterministic
and having instantaneous flips.
But they're the
same, so you don't
have to worry too much
about that distinction.
OK.
One more gadget before I
go to actual reductions.
And this is the definition
of a protected OR.
I call it protector OR.
Cause more ORs is better.
But protected OR
is the proper name.
Protected OR gadget
looks like an OR gadget.
So we're going to have
two inputs, one output.
And these are going to be
labeled which are which.
I want that at most one
input is active at any time.
What I mean here
is that if I ever
have the state where
both of these are active,
then the entire
universe explodes.
And I give no guarantees.
I mean, not only does
this gadget fail,
but all gadgets everywhere
could self-destruct.
Because we're going to
build some gadgets where
you really only want
one of these two things
to be pointing in.
If they both point
in, then the framework
that separates
gadgets may shatter.
And then gadgets are
no longer separate.
You can't argue about them.
And literally
everything falls apart.
So we'll see some
examples of that,
but this sort of foreshadowing.
It turns out we can set
things up so that you never
have both things
pointing into an OR.
Because we can build a fully
fledged OR out of those
protected ORs.
So this gadget acts as an OR
where these two are the input
say, and that's the output.
But it does so only
using protected ORs.
Now it uses a blue
to red transition.
So we have to again inspect
the blue to red transition.
This is where I wanted
that this is rigid,
that you cannot make
any moves in here,
because that makes me
happy about this OR.
This is the only
OR in this picture.
And I might worry, maybe I
could flip one of these edges,
and then I have two
inputs activated.
But because no edges can
flip from this state,
in fact, this guy will
only have one pointing in,
so no matter how you label
the inputs and outputs,
it is a protected OR.
OK.
So that part is fine.
And now this simulates an OR.
Do we want to go through it?
Hm?
AUDIENCE: Which of the
inputs [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So this is one input,
and this is the other input.
Oh.
For these ORs?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I'm going to
guess-- well, let's find out.
I don't remember.
So let's say this
guy is pointing in.
So if this is also pointing
down, then this can point up.
But if this is
pointing down, this
must point up and to the left
in order to satisfy this node.
So if this is coming in, this
one must be pointing out.
So I'm going to say
that's the output.
These are the two inputs.
I'm guessing
symmetrically, yeah.
If this one is pointing
into the vertex,
then that must mean
both of these red guys
are pointing into
that vertex, which
means this guy must be
pointing out of that vertex.
So if this one is active for
this guy, this guy's inactive.
And vice versa.
So this is protected
from those two.
Similarly over here.
But if this is active, and this
is down, and this is active,
and this is pointing up, then in
particular, this can point out.
And this guy's satisfied.
So then this edge can
point to the right.
And then this one
can point up here.
And this can point here.
So the AND actually
outputs a yes.
So if the left is activated,
then C can activate as well,
and symmetrically.
So this simulates an
OR, but it's guaranteed
that these two guys are happy.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I just want to understand
the motivation for this,
just to make our
gadget-building lives easier?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
This is just to make our
gadget-building lives easier.
It's so that I can now say
that deciding whether a planar
graph can do a sequence
of moves and flip an edge
is hard for AND
and protected OR.
So that's a stronger statement.
Now I only need to
build a protected OR.
In general, we want to reduce
the complexity of our gadgets
as much as possible for the
hard part, which is actually
analyzing a real problem.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wait.
So is protected OR
easier to build than OR?
PROFESSOR: Protected
OR is easier to build,
because you don't need
to worry about the case
for both inputs are active.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So you could
have any behavior.
You might have the
correct OR behavior,
or you could have any
other behavior, including
self-destruction.
Or universe
destruction, I guess.
So it could only
be easier to build.
AUDIENCE: This is
for future reduction?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
In fact, the very next
reduction, I think.
Or the one after that.
Close enough.
All right.
Let's do real
reduction, shall we?
So all of this stuff
that you just saw
was built for one problem
initially, and then
happened to be useful
for a lot more.
And that's sliding
block puzzles.
So these are a bunch of examples
of sliding block puzzles.
You have blocks-- let's
say typically rectangles--
and you're an
agent from outside.
You can pick any block
you want and slide it
along some non-colliding path.
So I can move this over, and
then move this over, and then
move this guy down.
In this case, the goal is
to move this block to here.
Because there's a-- well, I
think that's just the goal.
These puzzles go
back to the '20s.
Martin Gardner wrote about them.
And in his article, called
"Sliding-Block Puzzles,"
he says these puzzles are
in want of a general theory.
And there is no general
theory because they're PSPACE
complete.
There's no way to easily
tell whether a puzzle's going
to be solvable or not, which
is annoying for puzzle design,
but there you go.
Here's an actual instance
of the puzzle I showed you.
Dad's Puzzle, where
you take this one.
You're supposed to move it here.
This optimal solution
has 83 moves.
And in general,
number of moves is
going to grow exponentially,
because the problem is PSPACE
complete.
And here's the proof that
it's PSPACE complete,
in two pictures.
We need an AND gate
and an OR gate.
And the point is, so here the
notion of edges being active
is maybe reversed from
what you think about.
This edge is currently inactive.
And if I slide this
block out by one,
that activates that edge,
meaning it points up.
So right now the edge
is pointing down.
If I move this block down,
then the edge is pointing up.
So it may seem backwards.
But if you don't think
about it too much,
it's actually very clear.
What I mean to say is that in
order to move this block down
by one, I must first move
this block left by one,
and this block down by one.
So for this guy to be sucked
in, this guy must be kicked out,
and this guy must be kicked out.
Because then I can slide
this block over one.
And then I can slide
this block over and down.
Then I can slide this
down and then this down.
With that sequence of
moves, I can move this in.
But I needed enough
room to do it.
So that's an AND gadget,
an asynchronous world.
And the OR gadget, this guy will
be able to move in if and only
if at least one of these guys
moves out, because if say,
this one moves out,
this could move down,
this guy can move over,
and this can move down.
And if the other one happened,
this guy can move over too.
And then this can move down.
At this point we don't
need a protected OR.
Now you have to
think a little bit
about how these gadgets
are fit together,
but I guess that's
the next slide.
Before that, here we have 1
by 2 blocks and 1 by 3 blocks.
That's not satisfying
because it's not tight.
One by one blocks
are polynomial,
so we can't do
one by one blocks.
But it's turns out just
1 by 2 blocks are enough.
And these were found by a
semi-automatic computer search.
And I programmed it
[INAUDIBLE] to analyze.
In particular, these dots
mean that there will always
be one of the blocks
overlapping that position.
So like even if this
guy moves out by one,
this is still occupied.
And so you could use that
analysis to help cut down
the search and see that actually
all of the gray tiles cannot
move at all, assuming that you
don't have boundary effects.
And only the yellow
tiles can move.
And that kind of highlights
where the action is.
Again, if this guy slides
out, and this guy slides out,
then you get this
chain reaction.
And this can move down.
It needs two units of space.
And then this guy can move down.
And similarly, if this one moves
out, or this one moves out,
this guy has some freedom
about how he moves.
And there's a couple
extra units to gain.
Then this guy can move out.
Now this is a protected
OR, it turns out.
It's not going to be
obvious from the picture,
but if both of these move
out, the whole gadget
can fall apart.
So this is the genesis
of protected ORs.
But I won't go into
the details here.
I guess I don't have
a figure about how
the gadgets fit together.
But essentially these
corners interact.
Because here we're vertical
and here we're horizontal,
you get a little nexus
where nothing can move.
So as long as the
overall boundary
is fixed-- the big
rectangular box that we're
fitting in-- you get
this chain reaction
that because this point
is always occupied,
even if this slides
up or down one,
you transfer the
rigidity of this edge
to the rigidity of this edge.
And so you get that all of the
gadget boundaries are rigid,
and it's just the action
in the yellow tiles,
because of these
dots, basically.
And I think one thing
that might go wrong
here is if you could
move out by two,
then who knows what
happens, right?
Or is this guy could actually
suck in an additional spot
equivalently.
OK.
So sliding blocks.
Now I said one by
one blocks are easy.
But here's a slight
variation where it's hard.
In a graph, suppose
you have tokens.
And a move is to move
a token along an edge.
But at all times
the set of tokens
must be an independent set.
You can never have
two adjacent tokens.
So this is what you might call
reconfiguration independence.
And it's a reconfiguration
problem in the sense
that I'm interested
in two solutions
to the independence set problem
of the same size, in fact.
And I want to know, is there a
sequence of moves that converts
one solution to
the other solution.
In this case, by
moving it into one
of the vertices and
independence set along an edge.
And here you can very
easily simulate an AND.
This guy can move down
only if this moves out
and this moves out, because
of these constraints.
And an OR, this
guy can move down
only if this guy can
move here or here.
And to move here, this
guy must move out.
So you can see, you
get really short proofs
of PSPACE completeness.
Just need two pictures.
For fun and somewhat relevant
in particular to your p-set.
Let me mention another
reconfiguration problem.
I don't have a figure
for it, but this
is reconfiguration 3SAT.
So suppose I give you two
solutions to a 3SAT formula--
two satisfying assignments.
And my move is, flip a
variable from true to false,
or vice versa.
I want at all times to be
a satisfying assignment.
I claim it is PSPACE complete to
find a sequence of such moves.
This is originally approved by
[? Papadimetriou ?] and a bunch
of other people--
[? Gopala, ?] [? Colitis, ?]
and [? Mineva. ?]
But there's actually
a really easy proof
once you have nondeterministic
constraint logic, which
is-- so we're going to simulate
nondeterministic constraint
logic using this
reconfiguration problem.
So in order to represent an
edge in our constraint graph,
we will just make
that into a variable.
And true for that
variable means the edge
is pointed one way, and
false means the other way.
You just decide economical
orientation for each edge.
And then if we have an OR
vertex-- call the edges x, y
and z-- then the constraints
are that x must be in,
or y must be in,
or z must be in.
That's an OR constraint.
And "in" here means I write x
or x bar, according to whether
in is the positive or the
negative orientation--
the true or the
false orientation,
however you decided this.
So that's a 3SAT clause.
And an AND vertex,
say, x, y, and z,
is going to be two
constraints, two clauses.
If x is out, then y must be in.
And if x is out,
then z must be in.
OK.
So that's two clauses.
We AND them together,
we can convert a implies
into a not x out
or y in, as usual.
So these are 2SAT clauses.
You take the conjunction
of all those clauses,
you get a 3SAT formula.
And that exactly represents
that the configuration is valid,
that it satisfies the
inflow constraint.
And so reconfigurations
in the constraint logic
are identical to
reconfigurations
in the 3SAT instance.
Very nice simple
proof found by Sara.
So now you get the sense that
constraint logic is really
just a very simplified version
of reconfiguration 3SAT.
We have some very
specific constraints
on what we need to worry
about, some very specific types
of vertices we
need to implement.
And that's it.
So of course you could simulate
all of reconfiguration 3SAT,
but your life is going to be
a lot easier by simulating
this special case.
And you've seen already
a few examples of that.
OK.
Next problem.
Rush hour.
This one we actually
covered in lecture one,
so I just remind you that
here the blocks can only
move in the direction
but they're oriented.
And again, you can build
an AND or protected OR.
In the setup, this result
was proofed previously,
but here's a
constraint logic proof.
Again, we do protected OR.
Now this is 1 by 2
blocks and 1 by 3 blocks.
That's as far as we could get.
This is a picture
here we actually
see how things come
together at the corners.
So this is clearly a
locked configuration.
That's good.
And then Trump and
[? Cidibrasi ?]
came up with a purely
1 by 2 car version.
It's more complicated.
And they had trouble getting
just a single gadget.
So they ended up doing
two AND gates using,
I guess, rotational
symmetry here.
Two AND gates at once.
But of course, this is really
a split viewed from below.
So if you just
throw away that end,
and they have a way
to terminate things,
then that is just an AND gate.
And similarly, they had to
glue two OR gates together.
But that also can be
used to build an OR gate.
They built something
related to an OR,
but in particular,
it is a protected OR.
And so that's enough.
In fact, these actually
act as latches,
if you wanted to
be more efficient.
But you don't worry
about that, you
can use them as
protected oars, and then
build latches out
of that, and build
all the things we've done.
So that's cool.
An open problem in
the world of Rush Hour
is what about 1 by 1 cars.
Now this is a little
weird, because 1 by 1 cars
don't have natural orientations.
But if each car is
marked whether-- I mean,
you can see where
the headlights are.
So you know whether it's going
horizontal or vertical only.
It's open whether this
problem is PSPACE complete.
In the same paper, they
do a computer search
to find the hardest
5 by 5 puzzle,
and the hardest 6 by 6 puzzle.
I think with just one
blank space in here,
the first move is to
move this up, this up,
this right, this right, this
right, this down, this over.
The first chain of
moves, so to speak.
But it's 199 moves
to solve this.
This puzzle is 732 moves.
And it's drawn here.
That's the longest
puzzle that's 6 by 6.
So it seems to be growing
exponentially, maybe.
So maybe it's PSPACE
complete, but we don't know.
Triangular Rush Hour.
You can do that too.
Again, there's an AND
gate and an OR gate.
Here we had to build a straight.
But then everything
fits together.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I was just gonna
ask what is the goal in those?
Like, there wasn't--
PROFESSOR: Oh.
Right.
What is the goal.
I mean, if you put the
final edge of the reverse up
in the corner
somewhere, then there'll
be one car which can escape
through a little slot
in the exit.
That's the usual
Rush Hour setup.
If and only if
that edge-- Sorry?
AUDIENCE: The pictures
didn't specify.
PROFESSOR: The pictures
did not specify.
It's true.
Oh, and these ones.
I think it's like
one of these cars
is going to go out
through the right.
But I forget.
I think it might be the
second row, or the first row,
something like that.
OK.
So, cool.
Here's another problem.
Turns out to be related,
though it doesn't seem
like the same sort of puzzle.
This is called a
hinged dissection.
It's a chain of
blocks that folds
from one shape-- in this
case, equilateral triangle--
to a unit square.
Goes back to even before 1900s.
But this one's from 1900s.
Early 1900s.
And so that's cool.
In particular, there's a motion
that avoids self-intersection.
And we proved a few years
ago that for any two polygons
of the same area, there is
a finite chain of blocks
that can fold one into the
other without self-intersection.
So great.
Problem solved.
But that's good for if you get
to design the hinge dissection.
But what if you have some
existing hinge dissection
that someone came up with?
So this is earlier work.
But it's a chain of these
right isosceles triangles--
128 of them that can fold into
any letter of the alphabet
and any number and a square.
So you can follow the six
into a square into an eight
into a nine into a zero.
That's cool.
Open problem.
Can you do it without
self-intersection?
And it would be great if we
had an algorithm to tell us.
But it's PSPACE complete.
So if I give you a hinge
dissection, and I want to know,
can I get from this
configuration to that one
without collisions, you can
simulate essentially Rush Hour.
This is a gadget--
the hard part here
is to make everything connected
in one connected hinge
dissection.
And it can simulate this
block sliding to the right
or not in this kind of way,
avoiding collisions locally.
And so now it's just
each of these blocks
can slide left or
right or up or down.
And they have some weird shapes,
but it ends up working out.
So that's kind of a cool result.
This is before we proved hinge
dissections actually exist.
It was discouraging, maybe.
But when you're constructing
your own hinge dissections,
it's a lot easier
to avoid collisions.
All right.
Pushing blocks.
Remember this table
from Lecture 4, I think.
So we did a lot of the
NP hardness proofs.
But there are some
PSPACE hardness as well.
And I'm going to
cover these two.
So Sokoban first,
and Push 2F, second.
So remember, Sokoban
is this puzzle
where you want to get the blocks
into the target locations.
And you are walking around.
You only have the
strength of one.
You can only push
one block at a time.
So I think this is
Level 5 apparently,
in the original classic.
So this is a little bit
awkward in some ways,
because in constraint
logic, you're
supposed to be able
to flip any edge.
In Sokoban you have an
agent who's walking around.
So we're going to cut a
lot of tunnels in the walls
so that the agent
can go anywhere.
And then also, these blocks are
exactly where they want to be,
meaning there is a target
location where that block is.
There's only one block
that's in the wrong spot.
And so we're going to use our
configuration to configuration
thing to say, I want to solve
the QSAT formula, which lets me
move one block out of the way.
So I can move one block
that's in the wrong spot
down to a good spot
that's in target location.
And then unroll everything.
And then all the blocks are
back where they wanted to be.
And the one guy that
we needed to move
got to where he needed to go.
That's Sokoban.
And the rest is mostly
this AND and OR gadget.
The idea is, because these
guys are where they need to be,
if I move the D to touch the
A, you're permanently screwed.
You can never
separate them again.
And so you'll never be
able to fill some spot,
because D in particular,
can no longer be useful.
But every block
needs to be used.
And so let's see, in
order to move V down,
we must move- or, sorry.
That's the other way around.
In order to move C to the left,
we must first move B and E
up one, and A and D left one.
And you can check that
you can actually do that
by moving this out and moving
this over, and then pushing E
up, and then pushing B up.
Then C can move in.
And it is reversible
if you check carefully.
And for an OR, we just separate
these a little bit more.
So separately each
of them could move.
And then this guy could move
in and you won't be trapped.
If you just tried to
move this directly,
then you'll never be
able to get in here.
And so these guys are sort
of locked in position.
And that's bad news.
Or they could only get worse.
You could move A in here, but
then you're really in trouble.
Now once you do that, you might
have some parity issues because
of the widths of these gaps.
But you can build this
kind of extra-long tunnel
to change parity.
We talked about tunnels.
You also need turns.
And then you can simulate
constraint logic.
This is one of the weirder
constraint logic proofs.
It's not directly mapping
because of the agent issue.
But it turns out to work.
OK.
That was Sokoban.
Next one is Push-2F.
I will not cover
this one in detail
because it's quite
a complicated proof.
But I will tell you
that we can simplify it,
now that we know what we know.
This is a fairly old proof.
2002.
So it predates last lecture.
It predates the
[? Viglietta ?] paper.
So what we've constructed in
this case is a lock gadget.
This is just like the final
meta-theorem from last class.
We have an unlock traversal
where you could come in the U
and actually come back
out the same place.
It unlocks the thing, so you
could then go from I to O.
Or if you go from LI to LO,
you're forced to lock the door.
Sorry.
It was called a door
in the last class.
So that actually has a door.
Now we needed a door
and a crossover.
And you can build a
crossover like this.
I think at this point
we have a crossover.
So left of this line would be a
PSPACE completeness proof using
the [? Viglietta ?] framework.
We didn't have it
at the time, so we
did this part of the proof
also to build an AND and an OR
gadget.
We're essentially
doing the 3SAT thing.
And we're just checking
that all of the things that
need to be true are
true for AND and OR.
This reminds me of the
reduction from three
coloring to one of the other
pushing blocks problems.
Push-1X, I think.
We'll just check that all the
things that need to be true
are true.
So that's the rough sketch.
But there are a lot of
details getting it to work.
It'd be great to solve
Push-1F in the same way,
but that remains
an open problem.
All right.
That was pushing blocks.
Next we have rolling blocks.
So this is a class of mazes.
So this is how you usually
are given the input.
What this means, the red
things here are fixed.
And the green thing
is actually a 1 by 1
by 2 block sticking
out of the board.
And so it was in this position.
And you can roll it over
along one of the edges,
and it ends up occupying
this rectangle up here.
And you can keep rolling your
goals to get to t sticking up.
And it's not so easy.
Hence the dot, dot, dot.
So that's the traditional
rolling block maze.
And if you have a lot of
rollable blocks, in this case,
all the blocks are rollable.
So these red things are
actually sticking up.
And the green ones are
obviously lying in the plan.
And the 1 by 1 squares
mean that it's sticking up.
Then it's PSPACE complete
to roll a particular block,
because in order to
roll this thing down,
you have to make space
here, which means
this has to have rolled up.
Which means-- well, so if this
rolls out, and this rolls out,
it will be like here and here.
Then this can fall over,
replacing that rectangle.
This can fall over,
So that's this and this.
Then this guy can roll
down, so it comes here.
And then this guy can stand up.
And this guy can fall over.
So you get that picture.
And so it's AND game.
And this one is an OR gate.
I think I won't go
through all the things,
but if either this one comes
up, or this one falls over,
then this one can come down.
And you can show in
this case that it's
essentially impossible,
or never useful,
to make any of the
red towers fall over,
which lets you argue about
gadgets independently.
Cool.
That's a pretty recent result.
Oh, in this proof they also--
it took me awhile staring at I
guess these gadgets
to think, oh,
do these actually fit together?
This fits together.
But if I rotate this
one 180 degrees,
the A's will not match up.
And so you need a shift gadget.
And you also need a
sort of straight gadgets
for just indicating information
without any stuff going on.
OK.
Getting near the end.
Plank puzzles.
These are ThinkFun puzzles,
under that name River Crossing.
Although they predate
that a little bit.
So here you have again,
an agent moving around.
So we're going to have to do
some work to get rid of that.
And you can, for example,
walk along a plank.
Then you can pick that plank up.
And you can only carry
one plank at a time.
And you can place it, as long
as this is a length two plank,
as long as there's another dot
that's exactly length 2 away,
you can drop it down.
And then he walked
here and walked here.
Then that pickup, that
unit-length plank,
put it down here.
And I get to this
picture, then I
can walk here, walk here, pick
up this plank, put it down.
But I also could have walked
back to pick up this plank,
walk over, drop
it somewhere else.
But I can only
carry one at a time.
You want to cross the
shore, cross the river.
This is PSPACE complete by
nondeterministic constraint
logic.
And there's stuff going on here.
I mean, rough idea,
imagine you can sort
of teleport to some extent.
If this guy can move
over here, and this guy
can move over here, then let
me show you a bigger picture.
This is a bunch of
gadgets stuck together.
But also what we see are
the navigation mechanism.
There's a length three guy here,
and a length three guy here.
The length threes are the ones
that go around each gadget.
This is one gadget.
There's all these
length three distances.
There are no other
What that lets you do
is grab this, move it,
and basically you can
walk around the boundary.
Then you can also walk along the
boundary, grab this other guy,
and move it somewhere else.
So you can walk
along the boundary
and carry an additional
length three thing with you.
So that turns out to be
helpful in that when you're
trying to traverse
a gadget, you need
to be able to enter
from this side,
and also enter from that side.
And you can set up those
planks to make that possible.
I'll just wave my hand
and say that is possible.
It's a little hard to
see in these diagrams.
But you're getting
NCL reduction again.
And I have two examples
of non-puzzles.
Sort of real world
problems reduced
from nondeterministic
constraint logic.
One of them is
dynamic map labeling.
So there's a whole
field of map labeling.
One of the typical setups is
that you have points, features,
cities, whatever that
need to be labeled.
Labels are usually
model by squares.
Because if you scale
things, if they
were rectangles of fixed size,
you'd turn them into squares.
And typically you want to have
that square, one of its corners
should be at the dot.
So it's easy to read.
But now, suppose things
are changing in your map.
Maybe you're adding points,
or your zooming out,
or zooming in.
You'd like to continuously
change the labels
and you don't want any
labels to intersect.
So you could think of
zooming out on Google Maps.
I'm not going to talk
about the zooming
out, although this paper proves
that that is PSPACE complete.
Question is, how many labels
can I preserve and be able
make a continuous change.
Simple example is
maybe you add one city.
In order to be able to add
one city and add a new label,
probably something has
to move out of the way.
And then you can get a
nondeterministic constraint
logic argument.
I love this figure,
because it shows
all the gadgets and the
ways that they fit together.
This is a nondeterministic
constraint graph.
And an AND gate here.
The pinks are the inputs.
So if this square
can move over here,
then this one can
move up to here.
And if this one can
move over to here,
this one can move down to here,
then these two can move left.
Then this one can move left.
It overlaps both of
these, so both of these
have to move out of the way
before this one can move,
and that one can move.
And so on.
You can see how to build
a wire, which is just
a chain of these things.
There are these special obstacle
blocks which prevent you
from doing anything else.
cool.
And then OR is actually easier.
You just chain these
two things together.
And it doesn't matter
which one is the input.
This guy can be in
one of three locations
according to which
one it's directed in,
which corresponds to the blocks
being away, out of the way.
So continuously
changing map labelings
is going to be hard pretty
much however you slice it.
And finally, this problem
is even more complicated,
but it's a well-studied problem
in computational geometry
of searchlights.
So there are these dots.
And imagine you have
a laser pointer.
And so you can shoot a ray
in any direction of light.
And if the laser hits
the spy, the spy dies.
OK?
Your goal is to
eliminate all spies.
You have this
yellow region, which
is where all your treasure is.
And you want to make sure there
are no spies in the treasure
region.
So normally this is a
finding-the-spy problem.
If you ever see they
spy, you can capture him.
But the spy can move around
really fast while you're
moving your lasers around.
So how do you sweep your
environment with lasers?
Turns out it's PSPACE
complete to make sure
this region is empty.
And I won't go
through the proof.
But it's an
orchestration of laser
continuous reorientations.
And you end up with
ANDs and OR gates,
and crossovers-- that's
this gadget-- and then
the nondeterministic constraint
logic's happening down here.
You end up clearing all of
this space pretty easily.
And then there's this
little extra spot
that will only be cleared if
you get an appropriate laser
from this guy.
Then you could sweep up
to there and make sure
that it's clear without--
the worry is that there's
a bad guy over here, and
he somehow sneaks back
into the other region.
That forces some of
the lasers to stay
where they are, and
ends up simulating
nondeterministic
constraint logic.
Pretty epic proof.
But I will leave it at that.
And that's all for today.